good morning the last two bills we're
hearing this afternoon
uh were incorrectly both put in at one
o'clock
but
since the non-germain amendments i was
expecting
for both of them didn't come through
that means we can do them one after
all right
and it being 10 o'clock i'm opening the
hearing on senate bill 53 and i call
thank you madam chair members of the
committee welcome to monday hope you had
a great holiday weekend my name is grant
bosse from the new hampshire senate
pinch hitting this morning on behalf of
senator gray
chair of the senate election law and
municipal affairs committee he thanks
you for the courtesy of letting me
introduce this bill on his behalf
senate bill 53 began life last year as a
senator waters bill on a different
subject it was re-referred and the
committee ultimately decided not to go
forward with it
however chairman gray
decided to take the opportunity to use
this as a vehicle for some technical
changes
to the department of revenue
administration the bill is amended would
now clarify certain exemptions from rsa
21j 14 4
the confidentiality of department
records for the department of revenue
administration and it adds an exemption
for
municipal services and regulatory
responsibilities this would not only
clarify existing law but increase
transparency for the public
it passed unanimously and we would ask
for your support for as amended senate
bill 53. if you have any questions for
senator gray i can make sure he gets you
an answer thank you
do you know if this
is necessary considering the
we've
recommended moving the department of the
assessing board out of the dra is this
this is their existing and previous
records
yes thank you so i'm not sure how this
would play with the other bill
but i would assume we would if if you
move the dra the senate would recommend
this change moving along with it thank
you are there any questions for mr
bossie
okay seeing none thank you very much
thank you
good morning chairman and members of the
committee
oh okay
all right thank you thank you very much
good morning madam chairman and members
of the committee for the record i am
betsy patton member of the assessing
standards board representing the public
and i'm also the chairman of the
assessing standards board i'm here today
in support of senate bill 53
the asb was charged in 2001 to set the
requirements for certification and
decertification of assessors in their
duties of making appraisals of a
municipality
for tax purposes which is rsa 21j14f
these certifications and
decertifications were never intended to
be confidential or unavailable to the
public or the municipalities
if a complaint was found to be incorrect
and
then it would have been dismissed by it
would be dismissed by dra
this bill is a result of a situation
where the certification records of a dra
employee were requested and that request
was denied based on rsa 21j14
which as grant has said is the
department's authority for confidential
confidentiality of department records
the change in senate bill 353
will add the regulated responsibilities
of recessors i.e the certification and
decertification records to the
exemptions to the department's
confidentiality statute
again i would like to emphasize that all
the records of certification and
decertification were never intended by
the asb to be kept confidential
all assessors need to be accountable to
the taxpayers and municipalities they
work for the charge of the asb is to
have our system for property tax
assessment be transparent and open
please vote otop
wait a minute ought to pass on senate
bill 53 and thank you for the
there is no amendment the amendment was
done in the senate
thank you miss patton are there any
questions from the committee
representative schuett
thank you madam chair no questions i
just wanted to say hi to an old friend
thank you
good morning representative
representative schmidt
thank you madam chair good morning
madam chair of the asb i just wanted to
bring to the committee's attention that
senator gray is a member of the
standard board
and a very active participant on the
board so he is
fulfilling his responsibility as a
member of the assessing standard board
as i am
to uh also to monitor developments in
the board and and uh i wanted to just
give representative patton an
opportunity to uh to emphasize uh
senator gray's very active involvement
thank you
madam chair yes if you
the answer to the question you asked of
grant
is that this will be
make the conf the certification records
and decertification records open almost
immediately after his pass through
through both
instead of having to wait until the oplc
is up and running thank you good thank
you
any other questions comments
the chair perhaps uh senator this was
originally senator waters bill but
senator gray is standing behind it and i
don't see his name under the sponsors
yes representative that's because of the
non-germain amendment the sponsors on
the bill
never change no matter what you do to
and so i from i got the impression that
this was a bill that they killed
thank you thank you
okay
thank you miss patton is there anyone
else who wishes to testify on senate
okay
seeing none i'm going to close the
hearing
representative schmidt do you have a
motion
if we're going into executive session
madam chair i would absolutely take the
opportunity to
recommend how senate bill 53 ought to
pass
okay
schmidt and i think rhodes was first
do you wish to speak to your motion
uh
just to emphasize the point that uh
chairman patton uh did uh
inform us about and that is
that
senate bill uh 155
house bill 1552 that this committee
heard uh
was heard
was and during the course of that
bill it was referenced that the
assessing standards board as i say on
which i serve and have for
about the past 16 years
one of the reasons that bill was brought
and one of the reasons that senator gray
has brought this bill
is because it was never the intention of
the assessing standards board or the uh
the assessor community that the
certification and decertification
information was going to be
withheld from the public it was always
the intention that that record
those records should be
open to the public
and
in the fact that
that the dra overseas
under current arrangements oversees the
the assessor community winds up because
they are a very confidential
entity
and have a requirement to
maintain confidentiality of their
records they are doing the same thing to
assessors
uh and assessing officials
records namely withholding them from the
public and this the purpose of this bill
is to undo that and make that
information available to the public
so i i fully endorse the uh the bill and
hope that all of you will support it as
well thank you thank you brookson of
rhodes do you wish to speak to a second
no thank you madam chair representative
schmidt covered it okay is there any
representative goalie
thank you madam chair
the the only concern i have is
in passing this
we took a stance on moving the
assassin's standards board into oplc
for the reason of transparency
and if we pass this today
my concern is it gives the senate a
reason to vote down a position that we
have taken moving them to oplc
because we've taken care of the
confidentiality portion of it
that's the only concern i see about
doing this right now and moving it along
okay that's a reasonable point to make
representative lackas
thank you i understand that concern i
think there was another reason which was
a concern about the appearance of a
conflict so
it's not the only reason but
you're right it could be an issue
yeah
release from their confidentiality rules
not only
actions going forward but actions in the
past
which and i think that we would want to
have those open to the public regardless
of where the board is is located
but uh yeah i see your point
representative schmidt
um
i i think uh that
the point is very germane but the one
1552 is not just about the availability
of the records
the question is whether the assessment
the certification process certification
and decertification process
will be under the authority and the
oversight of the dra
the dra will continue to monitor and and
and serve as a
oversight board with regard to the
totality
of assessment
the thing that 1552 does it takes the
certification and decertification
process and the records
that this bill
speaks to
it takes the decertification and
certification process
away from the dra because that
that confidentiality aspect is something
that the assessing standard board and
the assessor community
never intended and do not wish to have
at this time
the the totality of the thing still
stays under dra it's the decertification
and certification process
that will be removed by 1552 so even
though representative goalie's point is
germaine
because it does not address the totality
[Music]
this bill doesn't it only does the
records this is just about the
availability to the public of the
assessor
records of
their certification and decertification
that's why it's more specific and this
bill is still needed
um so it's a there's it's a point to be
raised but the argument against it is
that this this is only the record part
the senate has heard house bill 1552 but
they have not yet voted on it i know
they're considering an amendment
so
what's the feeling of the committee do
you wish to proceed with this or should
we wait until the senate has moved on
yeah remember sign up goalie
thank you madam chair um
i guess the one point i will make is if
they do amend it it will have to come
back to us for approval and if it's not
to our liking we can
move forward
okay
good point
all right in that case we'll we'll
proceed
is there any further discussion on
okay seeing none the motion is ought to
pass on senate bill 53 and the clerk can
representative rhodes
yes
clerk was yes representative yakubovic
representative
yes representative allegro
yes representative bailey
yes representative lonzara yes
representative santos
yes
representative goalie
representative showed
yes representative judy we miss you
representative schmidt yes
representative marsh yes
representative fellows yes
representative fontenot yes
representative grota yes representative
uh
chair
okay the motion passes 17-0 is there any
all right seeing none we'll put that on
consent representative schmidt at your
earliest convenience
happy to oblige
well we have uh 15 minutes before the
next hearing so
thank
especially the vote
is that while we have a few minutes is
there anyone who has another bill that
i know a number of them are in
subcommittee
all right i guess not
take a break we'll resume it at 10 30.
maybe i'll take this
minute to remind representative judy
fontenot
o'brien's not here you and i that we
have a 10 30 wednesday appointment for
you
all right
now being 10 30
i'm opening the hearing on senate bill
thank you madam chair it's great to be
back with edna
and for the record i'm senator tom
sherman district 24 representing 11
towns on the
seacoast of new hampshire
and sb 220 came out of a series of
discussions
uh with people in the field of
psychology psychotherapy psychiatry
and also the director of oplc
lindsey courtney who can't be here today
but i think she has someone who is
coming to testify at least that's what i
was told
sb 220
reflects the concern
that one of the speed bumps to workforce
development in the state of new
hampshire is
that the licensing boards there are
multiple that deal with
mental health
licensing and they
can represent a significant speed bump
just
one example is that
if you if your license lapses
because you didn't receive notice or
there's a problem you have to start the
whole process over again
in one of the boards
another board
requires that if you've been in practice
for 35 years in massachusetts
and you come to new hampshire
they want a letter from the person who
trained you and that person may well be
dead
so that's problematic
so these are the kind of issues um oh
and one other point is that
other boards function really well
like in psychiatry it's the board of
medicine which is similar to the board
of nursing they move along fairly
quickly the turnaround time is
reasonable
having been through the board of
medicine myself
and
[Music]
you can have a reasonable expectation of
adjudication of your licensure
application whereas some of the others
it really seems to represent more of a
hurdle rather than something to just to
so we are all aware of the critical
shortage of licensed mental health
professionals in the state
and um
this pressure has only been exacerbated
by covid
uh they're in in the medical profession
we're looking at a 20 retirement rate
over the next two years nationally
so these challenges are not going to get
better and we want to make sure the
process of licensure isn't one of the
impediments to having a
so the bill creates a study committee to
look at ways to address these issues
by number one reviewing the licensure
criteria for mental health professionals
regulated by the board of licensing for
alcohol and other drug use counselors
the board of medicine board of mental
health practice board of nursing board
of psychologists
including how such criteria relates to
requirements in neighboring states
reviewing the licensure processes of the
office of the oplc as it relates to
mental health professionals including
how the statutory and regulatory
framework may impact
timely and efficient licensure of
qualified applicants
identifying and making recommendations
for joining available licensure compacts
regarding mental health professionals
which both decreases the cost
to the applicant as well as the
cost to
the process of licensing
exploring licensure barriers to
attracting qualified mental health
professionals to new hampshire
and making recommendations if necessary
for changes to the licensure regarding
the board of licensing for alcohol and
other drug use counselors and all the
other boards that i've already listed
um
i worked with oplc very closely on
crafting the
language of the bill
and if there are specific oplc questions
hopefully they will be here to answer
those
but i would also refer you to the
committee report from the senate
since this did not change
uh from as introduced
so i'm happy to take any questions
representative scientech
senator sherman you talked
he talked very fast so let me make i'm
sorry
but i'm very slow of hearing
um
this is administrative in intent is it
not you're not going to water down any
of the uh
absolutely so
the goal is to keep
the high level of
quality of providers in the state but
not
but right now some of the
boards
appear to have processes that may
block
qualified individuals from coming to new
hampshire
yes
we have heard heard that before
are there any other questions for
senator representatives thank you
um i'm just wondering about terminology
i i hear on the radio like
ads for you can get a therapist to help
you
using telemedicine
and there are these this company says
that they have 17 000 of them available
are therapists the same as counselors or
would they be covered by this
well i think the consumer has to be very
careful um or patients need to be very
careful to make sure they check the
credentials of the person
with whom they are
being counseled
there are all sorts of different degrees
that qualify you there's bachelor's
masters
there's a masters of public health in
counseling there's a counseling a
master's in counseling which my mom had
and she did counseling most of her
second part of her career
so all of these qualify you for some
level of licensure
and then there are others
who may provide pastoral counseling so
it might be somebody and
i'm not sure that's licensed through any
of these boards but that's also the
board of mental health practice is it
okay thank you
so there are
lots of different degrees and
qualifications and i'm glad to hear that
from the chair because
all of the you know competency is really
important because
you can do more harm than good if you
but it's the intent that you're going to
good morning madam chair and honorable
committee members uh
director courtney had a scheduling
conflict this morning so i am here
i did drop off a letter
expressing oplc support
and i don't want to rehash everything
senator sherman just said but
we agree that you know this is really an
attempt to remove barriers
to address the workforce shortages and
director courtney did spell out and
provide you with some percentages of
increase in licensure that happened
in the letter here
you know oplc does agree that these
changes need to be made
however it's not clear exactly what
changes need to be made and we do
believe a study committee
would help
address that
you know we are looking to other states
you know we're always looking for ways
to
increase the ability portability and so
forth without reducing the quality and i
think that's important so
i'll try to answer any questions if not
i can i can bring them back to director
courtney um
and she can respond back to you
all right thank you are there any
questions representative schmidt
thank you ma'am sure i'm wondering
because uh the this issue is the
colloquy up to this point has shown uh
has
been something that this committee has
been working with for a long time
these issues and sometimes kind of some
nastiness
among some of the professions especially
psychologists at one time we're a member
of the board of health
mental health practice now they have
their own board
so
one of the questions i have is of the
chair do we have time to have this go to
a subcommittee for any dialogue at all
or
representative schmidt are all our
senate bills have to be voted out of
that's what what i thought the
implication of that deadline was
so
of course it is a study committee and so
i'm going to be supportive thank you
okay thank you very much mr porter thank
you
is there anyone else who wishes to
sir please bring please uh introduce
yourself and when you're done make out a
thank you madam chair members of the
committee for the record my name is john
dejoy
i represent the national association of
social workers the new hampshire chapter
as well as the new hampshire
psychological association
i don't have a tremendous amount to add
so i'll be brief i'd be happy to answer
any questions i do want to point out
that social workers are part of the
board of mental health practice
psychologists do in fact have their own
board i want to make the make sure the
committee
recalls that psychologists have their
own
national interstate compact cypact
that has been it's been it's expanding i
believe it's up over uh 26
closer to 30 states now either are part
of sci pact or actively legislating to
become part of scipect uh that helps
with the portability we're just hearing
about in terms of licensure
mental health counselors who i do not
represent but they have a bill that just
went through this committee looking for
a compact for mental health counselors
and social workers would be looking for
a similar compact bill all intended to
assist with the portability of licensure
from state to state
with that if there are questions i'd be
happy to answer them
in terms of the in terms of the
committee
we will monitor the committee and
participate in any way that we can
uh committees in a second year are often
difficult they're difficult to to staff
they're difficult to meet
but i think the
content of the
of the bill is very important to
understand the workforce shortage to
understand and there and i will point
out there are a significant number of
issues many of which belong in commerce
not even in edna the issues about parity
the issues about compensation of parity
uh
so it may be that there's a need for
this committee and commerce to work more
closely on this broader issue to try to
really understand the
the issues that are getting in the way
of folks having access to needed mental
health care
and i realize that's not really an
answer i apologize yes thank you we
notice that too
representative fellows
yes thank you i'm just wondering if you
have any thoughts on whether the
shortage
of workers
in this area
might have anything to do with
educational programs for them not
being that available
thank you very much for the question
advanced training for mental health
practitioners is widely available i
actually teach at the university of new
hampshire
we have an online program we have an
executive program for the msw that
operates in manchester and we have a
face-to-face cohort in durham we
graduate nearly 200
new msws every year
um southern um
university of uh
new england i believe it's in southern
maine has a similar program
uh there are a large number of programs
and the on the online environment that
really exploded during covet has allowed
universities across the country to
provide education anywhere in the
country and a lot of students are taking
it taking advantage of that there are
other
structural issues that are getting in
the way and as i said many of those
issues belong in the domain of commerce
but
many practitioners many students that
does anyone else wish to testify on
all right seeing none i'm going to close
mike
do you think the committee might be
interested in emotion on this bill we
just heard
yes
um i make a motion of ought to pass sb
220. and i'll second the motion
okay ought to pass by representative
fellowes
seconded by representative marsh do you
wish to speak to your motion
representative fellow um yes uh this is
a study committee
it's not changing any legislation
but
um
it certainly seems to be an important
issue and one of the things i like about
this study bill is that it's
comprehensive and it's not addressing
just like a little piece of the
issues we think we have with licensing
it's comprehensive it's dealing with a
large group and i think that something
useful recommendations might come from
the study committee
thank you representative marsh
thank you madam chair i'll point out
that i'm one of the co-sponsors of this
bill yes and the reason that i did so is
that we are aware that new hampshire has
a desperate shortage of mental health
providers at this point in time as we
just heard a number of students that are
trained in this state are leaving in
this state and many of those reasons may
very well be structural based on the way
they're licensed in this state and if we
can easily address those issues we
really ought to do so that would be far
and away the least expensive way of
addressing this problem
so thank you for that all right
anyone else representative lackas
thank you yeah i'm
i'm not opposed to this i'm i'm willing
to vote for it my only concern is i mean
the one that was expressed here as a
practical matter
um
given probable complexity of this is the
committee going to be able to actually
come up with something useful in a time
allowed between when it's
you know this actually becomes
law and when
you know when the report's due which is
thank you representative rhodes thank
you madam chairman um i'm not
necessarily opposed to what they're
looking to study in
in senate bill 220 my concern is what
i've heard repeatedly from
multiple committees
is that
is a study committee in the second year
and my under my was under the
understanding the impression that
it
it really is frowned upon for many
reasons so i'm not really sure if this
wouldn't
necessarily be better to come
to come back whenever it actually can
have the study of the committee that it
needs so i'm not i'm not really sure how
to
how to handle the the conundrum that it
seems to present
anyone
okay i'd like to say that the scope of
this is almost entirely with an edna
and we could should we wish to study it
without having a formal study committee
if that were the choice of the committee
we don't need to pass this bill to get a
as i said a formal study committee with
the senator
in order to look at these issues because
we've heard
a large number of these
comments and concerns
from other people
i mean
representative fellows
um madam chair i i i think that
we need more than just the people from
edna to look at this i think we need
people um from the
medical profession to to deal with this
and i think that they're with the study
committee i think that we can find
come up with
you know one senator and
three
um
representatives that have a background
in in this um
you know they're they're doctors or they
they have a background in in social work
or whatever
that would be
um
in a better position to make
recommendations for this
thank you anyone else representative
scientific
even if this
we even if we cannot act on the results
of the uh
uh this committee i'm thinking about
senator carson who was in last week
talking about a bill i don't know i have
to look it up saying this is a result of
a study committee of years in the past
so this i would regard this as a first
step even if it doesn't
actually achieve orbit so
any other comments concerns
representative schmidt
thank you madam chair
um
so i i agree with my colleagues that is
late in the game but the bottom line is
that the old saying about is better than
light one candle and cursed darkness
and
i i think
that as much as i have a lot of respect
for
this committee's
overall collective intelligence
experience and so forth putting it all
on us especially when uh there was
testimony saying that
former representative de joy
maybe most members of the committee are
not aware of it but mr dejoy is the
honorable
john de joy who was in the house for a
number of terms
back in my early days
and he talked about commerce
uh also
might have been a committee that this
could have gone this bill could have
gone before
um so
to the degree that we put all the burden
on edna
it in our collective wisdom but our
collective wisdom is not so strong in
commerce and some other aspects
that this uh study committee
would be dealing with
so i think that that
i will vote for it too
uh because i think that we absolutely
have to try to get something
accomplished
there are all kinds of people here the
first time you see him out on the mound
or uh at bat you're going like this
guy's never going to make it in the
major leagues and a couple years later
he's at least
a journeyman so
nothing ventured nothing gained
since we have a moment uh representative
schmidt there's a better old saying than
light a candle with respect to this bill
and it is what james carville said
the best time to plant an oak tree is 10
okay
your representative lucas you had a
comment no no allegra
thank you i just want to express
practical concern for the number of
bills coming through proposing study
committees and our ability to
actually uh enact them in a fair manner
and that's all i need thank you okay
absolutely
yes foreign
thank you madam chair uh
with uh reference to mentioning the
other committees that
could likely be involved in this i would
hope if this
is adopted that our statement of intent
would include
the possibility of those other
members from those other committees
taking part thank you
as at the moment it specifies uh edna
the motion is ought to pass by
representative fellowes the clerk called
the clerk votes yes representative
jacobovic
yes
representative lekkis yes
representative allegro
no
representative bailey
yes
representative ludzara
representative santo nestaso no
representative goalie yes
representative schuett
yes
representative judy we miss you
representative schmidt
yes
representative marsh
yes representative fellows yes
representative fontenot yes
representative grota
yes
a little louder
no
okay so
it's up to 17 13 4.
that sounds about right
okay the motion passes thirteen to four
uh does anyone care to write a minority
report
okay well that is
it wasn't going to go unconsenting
representative sans anastasia will write
a minority report
and
i'll just mention that
it might be useful but i am
continuing and not voting for any study
committee that i wouldn't want to serve
on
all right representative fellows at your
very earliest convenience
and you and you also you also are
presumptuous
is it going on uh consent
no
with four votes against it's
probably too much representing the
all right you can't see your way clear
we could study it anyway
we don't need to study on this bill
that's the study committee and study
okay
11 15 and i'm a sponsor there so
hmm
oh
okay
huh
good morning i will open the house
hearing for senate bill 221 relative to
the internal organization of department
of corrections
uh senator reagan
good morning madam chair and members of
executive departments and administration
committee
this is my original committee 16 years
ago
senate bill 221 and it is relative to
the internal organization of the
department of corrections
and i brought with me the commissioner
of corrections
and she'll answer all your questions
[Laughter]
including representative schmidt's
question
well well played senator are there any
are there any non-questions from the
senator
thank you madam chair members of the
committee
i'm uh carol mcguire merrimack district
29 and
i believe my senator said most
everything that's necessary
but i will do want to add that there is
no fiscal note to this this simply
retitles the positions
and if the jcec needs to review them
they can do so once the new titles have
been established
there's not expecting any
cost effect from this change
and i will try to answer any other
questions
representative lucas
thank you so the only question is um
other than changing titles to what does
it really
reorganize
the organization of the department i
mean what kind of changes are
i don't believe so but you'd have to ask
are there any more questions for
representative mcguire
thank you very much okay
good morning madam chair and honorable
members of the committee uh it is a
pleasure to be able to answer questions
for you associated with senate bill 221
and i thank senator regan and
house rep maguire and others for
sponsoring this bill
the goal
was to align the names of two specific
division directors that already exist
unclassified and funded
one change was to take the director of
security and training and change that
name to the director of personnel and
information if you're not aware the
department of corrections has a line of
effort of significant need associated
with staffing employee development and
training for us to meet our mission and
it seemed odd that we did not have a
division director that oversaw our human
resource bureau
our training bureau and those lines of
effort so it takes those and puts it
under the current position referred to
in statute director of security and
training but asks to rename that to the
director of personnel and information
the other area we adjusted
is currently referred to as the director
of community corrections and every other
state the director of community
corrections actually oversees their
field services supervision effort our
director of community corrections
actually oversees the rehabilitative
programming across all locations in the
agency so you'll see we're asking to
change that to the director of
rehabilitation services
we did change some semantics underneath
that to recognize that that line of
effort under the director of
rehabilitative services should be
working to reduce recidivism we
shouldn't be working to increase
recidivism and target re-entry and
programmatic initiatives that do just
that
the
organizational adjustment as we move
proposing to move the bureau of victim
services under our existing director of
field services
to better align the effort of
restitution collection so that we're
making victims financially whole through
the process and those are the major
changes that we're asking for within
thank you are there any questions for
the commissioner
representative goalie
thank you madam chair
thank you for coming and taking
questions um
as i look at this and what's currently
in statute and what's here in front of
us these positions um in this bill all
say that they are going to unclassified
are they classified now or unclassified
positions that we are talking about
thank you for that question they're all
unclassified and would request that they
oh follow-up
i guess my question is why does it have
to specifically say in legislation when
it doesn't now in statutes say that they
are unclassified that we're putting in a
statute that they
it's my understanding the way the
statutes written because i have to
nominate and recommend to the governor
and the governor executive council that
they're unclassified we're just using
are there any further questions for the
commissioner oh representative schmidt
thank you madam chair um welcome
commissioner
long time no see but uh not uh
uh happy uh to uh when you're away too
long because uh
you're
uh
field your
your
corrections department
is one of the ones that
is
uh has one of the toughest
uh rows to host so to speak
uh and uh i think it a
a dialogue between this committee and
your
uh your uh your
department is an important one
so i'm glad we're going to have an
opportunity to see you today and ask
some questions and this
appears to be a pretty thorough
reorganization
of the department of corrections
uh and i'm wondering is this something
that is a result of an outside
analysis or this is homegrown
and that would be our first question
thank you for that question
representative schmidt it's a
combination of both it's an analysis now
that i've been in the position of
commissioner for the last four years and
also my ability to participate under the
correctional leaders association which
is an association of all commissioners
across the united states learning from
those encounters with them as well as
our own needs within the department
follow-up follow-up um so representative
goalie already asked uh along these
lines but uh
to the degree that you're changing names
and it's just a name change that's not
inappropriate and
we wouldn't have any reason to object to
that
but to the degree that you're changing
functions which you clearly are
in response to representative goldy's
question you got into some of the
changes which are change and function as
well as the name
um
so uh
is this the end of it or is this the
beginning of the process
at this point this is
what i'm prepared to put forward and ask
for i'm in a constant analysis of the
agency and it would be premature for me
to respond to that question at this time
i'm not i'm not um
i'm not prepared to even ask for another
particular bill this
session one more
as a member of the jcec
i'm
obviously interested whenever we have
uh
reorganizations
which of course the executive branch is
entitled to do
that's part of their function
um and um so
as this is
can we expect to see this on
our agenda jc you see anytime soon
representative schmidt if this has
passed and is signed off i will
certainly having facilitated things
through the jcec if that's appropriate
and where it needs to go next i will
take it down that path as well okay
thank you you're welcome representative
fellows
thank you madam chair
um i see that that one of the new
divisions you're putting together is
personnel and information
and underneath that the functions are
personnel management and recruitment i
understand that employment training
internal and external communication
in
bus in technology
and so i'm
confused as to why you would put those
things together i i don't really see
any connection between
i t
and
internal and external communications or
between
personnel management and internal and
external communications or business
technology so can you please explain why
you put those together
thank you representative fellows happy
to do that
both our external intra
internet page and we have an internet
page are highly used both to push public
information out about what we what we
actually do in corrections we are
certainly not a reality tv show and we
actually people who really do think that
what is it pink is the new black or
whatever those things are and so it's
important that our information
technology bureau is part of our
communication side in line of effort so
we communicate both to the loved ones
and attorneys and all of those other
constituents that are looking for
information that the right information
gets out and so there's an alliance
between our information technology and
our communications effort as well as our
employees for example police standards
and training council adjusted their
software platform that manages law
enforcement certification to a product
called benchmark so our training line of
effort we need to be able to pass that
information seamlessly to police
standards and training we have over 400
certified law enforcement members within
the agency so combining our
communications both written and
published through information technology
as well as our employee training and
employee development which we will and
do use online modalities of software is
important that they're all working in
cohesion to help advance our employees
follow up
um yeah can you tell me the process that
you use to develop this reorganization
certainly so um in working both with my
partners in ability with the
correctional leaders association and
reviewing other states
organizational charts and asking other
commissioners what's worked what hasn't
worked this is what we're experiencing
and doing that for the last several
years as well as doing exit interviews
with our employees that are choosing to
leave not retiring and asking them what
could we have done better
many things were centered around
employee development training and trying
to get a pathway to do that as you can
imagine our overtime budget is
significant and sometimes computer
technology is our fastest pathway to
communicate with our employees and push
information and training out so some of
it is studying and understanding how
other agencies have done it what their
successes have been
as well as
should i stop
as well as looking within the agency and
asking the employees that we've lost uh
what could we have done better and
that's informed these next steps
follow-up
um
yes just to follow up on when you're
talking about
training and development
so i'm thinking that
every state agency
has
has um at least a budget line for
training which usually is used to give
personnel
training that they can use to move up in
the organization
i'm thinking that
that correction collections is
pretty different from most agencies and
i would be thinking that
correct me if i'm wrong that a lot of
your training
goes to training the people
once you hire them to do their job
so
i'm just wondering about that
distinction and you're just putting the
training here
so what does that mean
certainly representative fellows by
having a division director of personnel
and information and dealing with both
called onboarding and training the
basics of what you need to navigate and
the numbers of disciplines it takes to
actually run a corrections environment
whether it's nursing social workers
corrections officers teachers case
managers the diversity of that employee
development and ongoing training so
where do they want to go within the
agency and how do we help them find a
path there employee development and
leadership training because of our rank
and file um having an officer could go
all the way up to be the chief of
security that all of those embedded
together in this division
we're investing in our personnel we're
investing in our employee development
and we're investing in what i would call
ongoing and natural training and that's
the just that's what we're proposing
are there any further questions
seeing them thank you very much thank
you for your time appreciate your
service to the state
are there any other members of the
public that are here that wish to
testify
saying none we will close the
this
on senate bill 221
representative rhodes
thank you madam chair i'll like to make
a motion of ought to pass for senate
bill 221.
i'll second
do you wish to speak to your motion
thank you madam chair i will yield to
you let you speak
thank you i already said what i had to
say
obviously a request of the department of
corrections it appears to be
well within their scope
of business and i i support them
choosing the names that they think most
appropriately fit their business
represent is there another anyone else
representative scitec
i don't know that this matters because i
did not compare it to the original uh h
21 h whatever it was but the word
resident is used in lines 25 and 30 on
page
two and they're not defined and does
that is that going to be any practical
problem
i i i should be here
looks like you have an answer to that
question
because in looking at the statutes
looking at many of the statutes the
statutes range from stating
convicts
offender
inmate person under departmental control
i think the nature of where this
language resides in the internal
organization recognizes we're talking
about people who are under the
responsibility of the department
there's
numerous
references to people who are charged
within our mission well if you don't
have a problem i don't have a problem so
all right
yes represent fellows
thank you madam chair um i i can
understand um
certain portions of this and it makes
that
there should be some reorganization
i just
you know and i guess i'm willing to give
them a try at this i just some of it
just doesn't make a lot of sense to me
like why it isn't under like the
administrative
business operations and you know and why
ex you know com
external communications
just doesn't seem to be in my opinion it
doesn't belong with personnel
but
if that's how they the only thing i can
say is that the department of
corrections has
very tightly staffed and people are
doing a lot of different things and if
this is the way they they choose to do
it like you i'm willing to give them a
follow-up yeah just um
i have something the rest of you are not
looking at but i believe that there is
not cur is it true that there's not
currently a person in the position
of director of over the personnel
operation
commissioner that's a factual question
that
there is a person in the position of
director of security and training as
it's statutorily referred to right now
all of our unclassified positions are
filled if this passes that person's
title would change to director of
personnel and information and is
personnel in part of that division
yes we're functioning under the
statutory authority of the commissioner
to other duties as assigned
and functioning quite well i think we've
done that
thank you thank you
representative scitec this sure sounds
like an echo of what we've just gone
through with a health and human services
where
it's tightly staffed they took advantage
of openings moved people around and we
had to have
a
charlie arlinghaus come in and
straighten out the whole shebang for us
so it's
not the least bit surprising that this
is going on
okay
anyone else
you're john schmidt
thank you ma'am sure um i think you
stated extremely well uh
in your opening remarks
and and i think one of the key factors
uh that we should take into
consideration
is what the commissioner herself said in
her testimony which is that we
that she has now been commissioner for
four years
so she was with the department before
but but it's only been under her
leadership for four years so she's had
the time to to uh you know
to work with these positions these
individuals and with these titles as
well and to the degree that now she has
the authority to do so
she believes that the terminology needs
to be changed
i think we should let her do that
all right
the motion is ought to pass by
representative rhodes the clerk can call
the role representative rhodes
yes the clerk votes yes representative
yakubovic yes
representative
yes
representative allegro yes
representative bailey
yes
representative lonzara yes
representative santa anastasia yes
representative goalie
yes representative show it
yes
representative judy lee mission
representative schmidt yes
representative marsh yes
representative fellows yes
representative fontenot yes
representative grota yes
the chair
yes
uh 17-0
all right the motion passes 17-0 is
there any objection to consent
seeing none we'll put it on consent
representative rhodes it's your very
earliest convenience
excellent
all right
um
we have two bills at one o'clock and so
you're off for lunch
unless somebody has anything else we
could profitably do can we execute these
two
we do
okay
see you at one o'clock
hey welcome back
uh
i'm opening the hearing on senate bill
thank you very much and good morning
good morning for the record i am senator
rebecca perkins quoca representing
senate district 21 which is the city of
portsmouth in the towns of madbury lee
durham newmarket newington and newfields
the prime sponsor of sb 218 an act
declaring october 13th as metastatic
breast cancer awareness day
sb 218 is
a refill of bill that we passed in the
senate last year through senate edna and
is the request of a portsmouth resident
um
laura inahara founded the more fight
more strong movement after losing her
dear friend jessica moore and seeks to
build awareness about metastatic breast
cancer and its important differences
from other forms of cancer metastatic
breast cancer is devastatingly deadly
with
over a hundred americans dying from it
every single day
while 98 percent of breast cancer deaths
come from metastatic breast cancer only
5 percent of breast cancer research
dollars are devoted to metastatic breast
cancer sb218 will help bring light to
this disparity and increase awareness of
the grim reality facing many of our
constituents
madam chair i will leave it at that and
i am more than happy to try to answer
any questions
thank you are there any questions
representative rhodes
thank you madam chairman thank you for
taking my question um i'm going to be my
friend representative pearson to the
punch
whenever i ask if um anybody has
what is the exact word i'm looking for
about recognition instead of having a an
annual day yeah thank you so much for
the question representative so governor
sununu did declare um october 13th of
metastatic breast cancer days so this
would just be a bill to
have october 13th of every year be
recognized as such
thank you
thank
representative scitec you uh senator you
said of every year uh isn't this hasn't
the senate sent us bills like this where
they
uh amend amended to be just that one
year
has the senate done that
not on this topic
okay that's what i'm used to seeing or
okay
thank you
other questions
seeing none thank you senator
is there anyone else who'd like to
uh
no but i i have a question madam chair
yes
do we
this i guess it's to you right because
no one's in the hot seat do we is there
a national metastatic breast cancer
okay if there is no one who who wishes
confirm
today is monday
and
i'm going to open the hearing on senate
bill 219
which
this
is also right
senator perkins spoke us if you'd care
yes thank you everyone and for the
record again senator perkins coca
representing district 21 city of
portsmouth
and surrounding towns i'm the prime
sponsor of sb219
an act declaring the month of september
as kinship care awareness month
sb 219 is a request of portsmouth
resident denise richard
denise is the founder of step up parents
a local organization designed to provide
emotional
practical and financial assistance to
relative caregivers who have assumed
child care responsibilities due to
substance abuse disorder problems for
the biological parents
we have all heard the heart-wrenching
stories of children affected by the
consequences of substance use disorders
as well as the uplifting stories of
relative caregivers who take on the
burdens of that situation and provide
the child with care attention and love
kinship care awareness month will help
recognize those who are taking the
extraordinary challenges of child care
on in such difficult circumstances
madam chair i will leave it at that and
i'm more than happy to answer any
questions thank you very much are there
any questions
representative peterson thank you madam
chair senator we we see a lot of these
right and
some of them have fun things involved
with them in reference to celebratory
gunfire or
things of that nature this particular
doesn't seem to ask
anybody
to do anything
i mean
like there's no i
call it a call to action or
something along those lines
um
so i'm just wondering what you
envisioned that
if this was to become law in september
be
became this and 37 other things that
that are september what would this what
would this look like
sure i think that um it's an opportunity
for organizations such as step up to
um
know that there's a month where they're
sort of heightened awareness of this
challenge that exists in our communities
to do you know some fundraising to
sustain these organizations and um to
hold events
sometimes featuring you know local local
elected officials to make sure that um
there's sort of a spotlight on this
all right seeing none thank you very
much senator
thank you very much
is there anyone else who wishes to
all right seeing none
and does
thank you madam chairman
um
well i think i'm going to do um senate
bill 2-8 i'm sorry
that's a lie
um i actually like to make a motion of
an expedient to legislate for senate
bill 219.
representative second by representative
219 yes
do you wish to speak to your motion
yes madam chairman um
so
when i'm not in in concord i i actually
work up at the uh the school district in
my town and i do recognize the the
challenges and the
the heartbreak that that a lot
of children uh go through especially
with with all of the different struggles
that a lot of their parents have um
however i i still go back to our our i
feel like it's the same paragraph that
we say over and over in the committee
which is i i think that if there was a
group of people that
that organized and got themselves
together annually
and they were to
approach the governor and ask for an
awareness day
i recognize that this is a month um but
nonetheless i think it's the it it's
still it's going to be the same effect
and i think that if you have this group
collaborate together that there would
actually be a lot more awareness brought
to the to this particular subject and i
think that they would actually probably
get more news coverage
um and get a lot more community
involvement that way because they can
actually have the day be what they want
the day to be
representative lakas
thank you yeah i i agree um you know
maybe they could get together even
organized people to volunteer to help
give people providing that kind of care
or break i mean i'm familiar with this
we had our oldest granddaughter living
with us
through high school because her mother
was having difficulties at the time so
it's not that i don't care about this
but i think that there's much more
effective ways of raising awareness i
don't think this would because
i think the governor staff just gives
them something to sign on the right day
they do a press release
unless there are people out in the
community doing something more to raise
awareness that's where it ends
and so i just don't think this sort of
thing's effective it's not that i'm not
sympathetic to
your the constituent's uh you know
interest in this
okay any other comments questions
senator has brought to us two important
issues
i'm not a fan of any of these kinds of
memorials because i don't think they
have much meaning
on the other hand these are important
and i would like to ask whether
sort of
hinting what i hinted at during her
testimony earlier is there any appetite
to
get an amendment to make these uh for
this year and
um
go forward with them on the one on this
one year basis and see what the next
year brings but i don't think i want to
so i'm asking the committee i guess if
if that would
how people might feel about that
because i'd be willing to i'd certainly
vote for that for uh
while a one year month or a day so
all right
any comments
representative rhodes oh thank you madam
chairman one of the things that i
actually just wanted to bring up
when i was
taking our small lunch break i just
happened to turn to the right page of
the 2017 laws in the book to see that
last week was actually
that last monday was actually john stark
day i
i didn't know that
um i feel like if again if that was if
that was brought as an individual day i
think there would have been a lot more
coverage and we all probably would have
known
okay represent representative broda and
then sciatic
i wanted to offer to representative
seidec scitec
um
and understanding what he said and if he
wants to work with me on these i will
help with that
okay representative
well accept your offer we can just we
can adopt that we can draft the
amendments i don't know what the rest of
the these these guys will do that's what
we can do we can draft the amendments
okay but let me continue john stark has
been dead for an awful long time and
they're not a lot of relatives that are
going to be eating the drum form
these are contemporary issues and by
giving them the recognizing the day or
the month
this year
we give some
additional
impetus for anything that local
communities or local organizations may
want to do
it just provides a
a nice background for what any efforts
that they might want to do
so i
let's leave john stark in
in memory thank you
representative blackis
i mean
without having
any statute this year they were able to
get a proclamation and there may have
been other activities that i'm not aware
of
and that could happen again this year
next year um
i really don't see doing this sort of
thing as adding much it's really
kind of a grassroots or a community
doing something
and making things visible and then maybe
not just commemorating it but doing
something to help the people in those
situations as well
um i'd i'd i'd
you know i would be maybe less opposed
to having to be one day than something
that's in statute that would be there
automatic and generally ignored after a
certain amount of time i believe
uh but i'm not
you know i wouldn't um
okay
representative
i just don't see this as the purview of
the legislature i think it's a
it's a much richer effort anyway when it
just comes from the citizenship
and i always remind myself that we have
65 000 pages of laws
of rsas
and adding another for these kinds of
events i don't think is
is
our job
and especially adding one
for just one time
um so
that's all i need to add thank you
anyone else
represents
yeah representative alegre this would be
likely to be chapter laws so it's not
going to swell the books for very long
and we'll let them struggle with it next
year so
i i would like to address that please
chapter law or otherwise i just don't
think that
this should be done by law of any sort
this should be done by local
organizations
and
and citizens
but
what's that you're close to convincing
i'll buy you beer afterwards okay anyone
else
comments questions
the motion is an experience of legislate
on senate bill 219 and the clerk can
call the rule
well i'm going to vote against
or
get an amendment
yes if this motion fails we will
okay the motion is itl
on uh 2 19.
um
okay
representative rhodes
the clerk votes for his amendment yes no
no uh representative pearson
no i want to see an amendment
oh he's not he's not here representative
yes
representative allegro yes
representative bailey
yes
representative lanzara
no
by representative goalie
yes
representative show it
representative schmidt
yes
representative marsh
no
representative fellows no
represent
representative grota
no
representative o'brien
yes
the chair
eleven two
six
that's too bad the motion passes eleven
to six
is
are you going to write a minority report
representative seitec
or representative groudon okay no
minority report i don't think that
should be on consent
so we'll put that on the regular
calendar
okay
the motion is itl on senate bill 218.
allegro will second all right do you
wish to speak to your motion
uh yes thank you i mean it's
it's basically the same argument as for
219 um
you know i've certainly known people
who've had breast cancer died of it i
don't know what kind
it's not a matter of being unsympathetic
and there's a lot of
public
awareness raising events activities
symbols and all of that
for breast cancer in general which i
i support
i just i don't really think that adding
an official day which is basically
going to generate in some you know
press release of a uh
a proclamation which is i think all it's
going to do
uh is of any point at all and is going
to contribute
to that awareness thank you
representative marsh
yes one of the differences however is
that october 13th is national metastatic
breast cancer awareness day
and i think it's appropriate for the
state of new hampshire to join the other
okay anyone else represent scitec well i
agree with representative
lekkis i'm not going to vote with him i
still want my amendment
so uh i'll be voting against ito
representative goalie and then pearson
well i agree it is
already observed nationally
i don't think
bringing an amendment forward um
is
the appropriate thing to do i think the
appropriate thing to do is for those
involved with this
should approach the governor for a
proclamation through his office and not
through the legislature
to me that's the more appropriate thing
that
brings out folks
gets them down on the front steps as he
does the proclamation on that day versus
just putting it in statute and leaving
with all the others as i look up
october 13th
all the other recognitions that go on
world thrombosis day international
planning language day metastatic breast
cancer awareness day national yorkshire
pudding day national train your brain
day and it goes on and on
i think it's more appropriate to have it
done that day and have the governor do
it and bring it forth to him versus just
putting it
in statute thank you thank you
representative pearson
thank you madam chair i am
conflicted
i'm not a big fan of the days that's not
a secret um but in this particular case
it being a a recognized national day
already
i can't recall what we did
last october 13th what the governor did
i would imagine it was recognized
um
so i guess the the matter is do we
codify this into a state
day
to coincide with the national
recognition
i'm looking at a veto proof majority out
of the senate i
it's uh it's 17 senators on this bill
this one i'm probably okay with as a
general rule i'm not but
considering that there's already
a lot of national attention which is why
i'm conflicted the national attention
that exists for this bill
is substantial so does this really add
to what the state of new hampshire is
doing
over and above the substantial
recognition that occurs at the national
level i don't know if that answers yes
or no i don't know that it necessarily
is but
this is why i'm
conflicted
oh i didn't realize i had my hand up but
i did never get to
comment on my second
i'm gonna provide a little personal
context to this i don't often do that
but i have a or had a beloved sister who
passed away from metastatic breast
cancer
i'm certain that she wouldn't want this
kind of
um
thing i don't think it does anything to
further the cause
um i think it's largely symbolic
and
with that kind of loss i'm i don't know
how else to put it i'm not into
symbolism
representative rhodes
thank you madam chairman
i think that everyone in this
in this committee probably knows
of someone
that has
that has lost a life due to um
to breast cancer i don't think that
anybody
um is not sensitive to that at all
but the question that i would have and
it was after representative pearson was
speaking is exactly
what would it
what would
what would making the day what what
exactly is it going to do
um
and i did look up to see in you know if
there was something national and i you
know i did look it up because i do know
that there's
certainly a lot of events i know that
there's um you know the city of
pittsburgh they have a
um
a big marathon on that day um so i think
going along the lines that we've done
with all of the other awareness days or
awareness months
is is probably with with nationally is
is probably the better way to go i just
don't know that this is going to do
anything other than doing what we
already do nationally
and i think that i really
watched what i was trying to say but i
think that i got the point across so i
apologize
any of any other
representative peterson are you talking
about forever or the uh the proposed the
putative amendment that i'm talking
about
the national recognition of this day is
i would presume in perpetuity so i'm
going to agree with representative
goalie that a single
turning this turning this into a single
year event is a waste of time it's
either we're gonna do it or not it
and
it you know that's uh
i appreciate the senator sticking around
to
you know watch us make sausage here but
um
but i yeah i don't i don't know that it
i don't know that a amendment's gonna
it's gonna change this at all
okay representative
there's a little bit more to it
representative goalie the governor is
very aware of ceremony and he can sign a
bill with as much fanfare as he can make
a proclamation the difference is that
this shows it's not just the governor
but the legislature's behind this
so
i'm fighting for a cause i'm not
ardently interested in but for the sake
of
excellent representative goalie
thank you madam chairman just a quick
follow-up i
represent a scitec i understand where
you're coming from but in i think in
doing this
we will be doing this yearly instead of
thank you gentlemen
is there anyone who has a a real comment
or concern questions
sorry
okay
so the
no one else
the motion is expecting to legislate on
senate bill 218
and the clerk can call the roll yep
representative rhodes yes
the clerk adamantly votes no yes uh
yeah
uh representative
no you're still not here uh
representative lekkas yes
representative
yes
uh
the clerk voted
wait a minute yeah i'm not sure
yeah i i i've
excuse me i'm going to restart because i
have reversed i've been thinking ought
to pass when it's ito
uh
representative rhodes you have voted
uh the clerk votes no on itl
representative pearson how do you vote
yes
uh representative lekkis how do you vote
on itl yes
uh representative allegro yes
representative bailey
yes
represent lonzara yes
representative santo nestaso yes
representative goalie
yes
representative show it
no
representative judy
we miss you are we we
uh representative schmidt yes
representative marsh no
representative grota
no
representative o'brien
and the chair
yes
five what's wrong with you people
okay
twelve to five uh ipl prevails
thank you the motion passes twelve to
five it will not be unconsent
is there anyone who would care to write
okay so seeing none will not have a
minority report so just just for the
senator's benefit this this committee
isn't
exceptionally consistent when it comes
to proclamations of days
just
just so you understand the background on
this
we need renegades
we did
is there anyone who has another bill
okay seeing none in that case
we'll close the executive session
have a nice afternoon enjoy the sunshine
we're back tomorrow
and we will uh
you're entitled really to tomorrow we
have
um
two four or five bills plus a non-german
amendment
what's up
they're good for it
we had a good meeting with us
you